I know what my father was what he did I
know the Mad King earned his name kill
every Targaryen get my answer
everyone who wasn't
isn't anything what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another game
of thrones discussion video today I want
to talk about some of the greatest
fighters and Game of Thrones I have seen
people debate about this many times
before but I haven't seen anything
recently that covers of the current
fighters that are actually still alive
and active in the story which means we
had to have seen them last season so Sir
Arthur Dayne Barristan Selmy and Oberyn
Martell will not be included in today's
discussion because they are dead also I
don't want to use any other quotes from
the books
I just want to base it on what we've
seen these fighters do on the television
screen now that season 7 is over we only
have one season left with that in mind
who do you think is currently the
greatest fighter in Game of Thrones
I am going to list 10 different
characters and I will be giving my
opinions but let me know what's one you
think is the best at this point in the
story the order I put these names in are
not set in stone depending what happens
next season some of these names can move
around a bit but let's just start off
the list with Sir Jaime [ __ ]
Lannister if I were making a list of the
greatest fighters of all time
Jaime would be ranked too near the top
even though I am keeping book quotes out
of this video
Jaime still has a reputation in the show
of being one of the greatest swordsman
to ever live we got to see some of his
skills put on display when he fought Ned
Stark back in the first season and then
we saw them again when he fought Brienne
of Tarth she did end up kicking his ass
but Jaime's hands were tied and at that
point he had been a prisoner of the
Starks for quite some time so he wasn't
exactly in shape to be fighting but even
with that being said we could still see
some flashes of Jaime's skills during
that fight unfortunately for Jamie he
ended up losing his sword hand which was
basically like losing his entire
identity as a man one of the very few
things people respected about Jaime was
his ability to cut through just about
anyone but now he has lost all of that
he did train with his other hand but he
did not get the results he was hoping
for in fact now that Jaime has to use
his other hand he is lucky to even be
able to defend himself at all he has
almost died on two separate occasions
while trying to use the other hand and
even though he has a Valyrian steel
sword right now
I can think of several other characters
that I would rather have carrying that
sword he may get lucky next season and
kill a white Walker with widow's wail
but let's face it Jamie will never be
the swordsman he once was the next
fighter I want to talk about is beric
Dondarrion this is a character that I
love and he also has a badass weapon but
I have to be honest I have to put beric
near the bottom of the list because
there are many fighters that I would
rank higher than him the fact that beric
Dondarrion has been resurrected six
different times tells me he gets his ass
kicked pretty often almost every time he
is backed into a corner he is killed we
have seen him hold his own for a short
period of time against the Hound who in
my opinion is one of the best fighters
of all time
I gave Barrack a lot of respect for
stepping up to the plate to face the
Hound in one verse one combat but with
that being said he was still killed
during that fight I even think it would
have ended a lot faster if barrack
wasn't using his flaming sword he knew
the Hound was afraid of fire and he knew
by having this flaming sword it would
give him an advantage but it still
wasn't enough to win the trial by combat
it's not that big of a surprise because
most men would be killed by the Hound
besides of that we have seen barrack
fight beyond the wall against hundreds
or even thousands of whites and he held
his own barrack did stand his ground and
he helped beat them back just as much as
anyone else that was standing next to
him
so obviously Barrett can still put in
some work but given his track record of
dying six times in battle forces me to
rank him low on the list now I want to
talk about grey worm and I got to be
honest again I was not very impressed
with grey worm or the unsullied at first
I knew they were an elite force but it
seemed like it took forever until we
really got to see them all in action and
grey worm has proven himself to be a
great fighter since then we have seen
his skills put on display quite a few
times now when grey worm Jorah and
Daario snuck into young Kai we get to
see just how deadly he was with his
weapon of choice then grey worm in
Barristan Selmy were outnumbered and
surrounded by the sons of the harpy grey
worm was able to kill several men with
his spear in very close quarters and
somehow he was able to survive the
attack while on the other hand Barristan
Selmy was killed
rest in peace Berenstain in season six
we get to see grey worm do this badass
move on the Masters then he led the
assault on Casterly Rock so it's pretty
obvious grey worm can hold his own just
fine but we have yet to see him fight
any actual bosses which makes it hard
for me to put him any higher let's see
how he fights in the snow against the
army of the Dead then maybe he can move
up a few notches all right so let's move
on to my next pick which is Sir Jorah
Mormont having been exiled from Westeros
from selling poachers into slavery the
night informer heir to Bear Island took
up work as a mercenary in the Free
Cities before that Jorah was said to be
at the Battle of the Trident and he
fought at the siege of Pyke during the
Greyjoy rebellion and he was knighted
afterwards by Robert Baratheon in the
television show we see Jorah kill wanna
draw goes blood riders in the very first
season we also see Jorah skills put on
display in the fighting pits Jorah has
to defend himself against several
opponents and he does survive the only
problem with Jorah is he's getting very
old and because of this he has almost
died a few times when he faces the water
dancer in the fighting pits he was
seconds away from being killed but he
was saved by the bow then when they go
beyond the wall Jorah struggles against
one of the whites thankfully Jon was
able to kill the white Walker which then
caused all of the whites to crumble but
that white was coming very close to
choking Jorah to death he can still
carry his own weight but Father time is
taking its toll on Jorah Mormont I would
like to put him higher on the list but
there are still a few people that I
think could handle Jorah pretty easily
if it came to that so let's move on to
the next one it was hard for me to put
Bronn of the Blackwater in the middle of
the list because I see him as a
jack-of-all-trades bran is experienced
with several different weapons which
makes him a very valuable asset in my
opinion bran can kill people with a
sword with a dagger and with a bow and
arrow
he's even hit drogon with the ballista
if you put any weapon in bronze hands
he's going to do damage almost
immediately after he was introduced he
was winning Tyrians trial by combat now
I know he did turn down Tyrion second
trial by combat but most men would
against the mountain on the other hand
he was ready to fight his brother the
hound
and I have to respect him for that
because that takes balls or stupidity
either way it took guts right before the
Battle of Blackwater Bay these two came
very close to fighting each other to the
death and I still wonder how this fight
would have ended I assumed the hound
would have won but at what cost
I don't think bran would have went down
very easily what I really loved about
bran is he's not afraid to get his hands
dirty and every time I see him fight he
makes it look very easy as if he's
always one step ahead of his opponent
the only thing is we haven't seen bran
get into an actual boss fight yet and I
would like to see how he stands up
against the enemies in the snow
hopefully he goes north with Jamie
because I need to see him in action
against the army of the dead now let's
talk about Arya Stark typically I would
not have her this high on the list but
based on what I've seen her do against
Brienne I had to put some respect on her
name now do I think Arya can go
toe-to-toe with bran and kill him not
necessarily but given the fact that Arya
has a particular set of skills I think
she could kill just about anyone under
different circumstances
Arya can wire different faces she can
slip behind enemy lines without being
detected and she can even kill people in
the dark she was trained not only by
Syrio Forel but also by Jack and Hegar
can you name any other character that
has had better training than Arya I
don't think so
now that she's older and a little bit
bigger combined with all of her training
this makes her very deadly
she has needle in a Valyrian steel
dagger and I think we will see her kill
at least one white Walker next season
which very few people can say they've
done what can I say about torment other
than he has been one of my favorite
characters ever since his introduction
even when he was technically on the
opposing team I could not help but love
this guy and he has proven time and time
again that he's an absolute badass I
almost had a heart attack when all of
the whites swarmed over him when they
were beyond the wall just for a few
moments I thought they were actually
gonna kill him off the show and I would
have been heartbroken then they did it
to me again when they put him on top of
the damn wall when it came crashing down
thankfully he was with the only
character that has nine lives like a cat
if anyone ever wants to question
torments fighting ability all you need
to do is watch him during the
the bastards torment has technically
been in to bossfights the first one was
against our Alliser Thorne during the
Watchers on the wall episode then he
went absolute savage again small John
umber at the Battle of the bastards I
would be confident with tormund fighting
just about anyone as long as he is
properly equipped with the right weapon
the next person I want to talk about is
Jon Snow now if this was a list where I
was ranking the greatest fighters of all
time Jon might not even be on the list
at all but when you compare him to the
current remaining characters from Game
of Thrones I think there is a case to be
made for him being one of the best
that's still alive one of the biggest
knocks against Jon is the fact that he
was nearly killed by Carl tanner who was
a fukken legend of gin alley I might add
when they fought Jon had his Valyrian
steel sword and Carl only had two small
daggers yet he was moments away from
killing Jon but John ended up being
saved just like Ned was saved
Craster's daughters stabbed him in the
back then Jon got up and finished off
the job with that being said I still
have to put Jon very high on the list
for the simple fact that he has held his
own on so many occasions Jon was cutting
through wildlings and things during the
battle for Castle black
Jon was cutting through Bolton's during
the Battle of the bastards Jon was
cutting through White's during the
mission beyond the wall and most
importantly he has killed two white
walkers they weren't lucky kills either
he went toe-to-toe blow-for-blow
and won both times which is incredible
also when and if Jon kills the night
king he will go down in history as one
of the greatest fighters of all time the
next person on the list is Gregor
Clegane who was also known as the
mountain some of you might not know this
but he was actually knighted by Rhaegar
Targaryen and in a twisted turn of
events he pays Rhaegar back by killing
his children gregor clegane is an
absolute monster he is far taller and
stronger than everyone else and he has
no morals or emotions other than rage he
has pretty much dead at this point which
means it could be tricky when trying to
kill him for good
not only that but he wears some of the
biggest armor I have ever seen and he
carries a sword that most men could not
even pick up this guy is a freak show
I would be worried if any of my
favourite characters had to face him but
I cannot put him at the top of the list
because
Martell did expose some of his
weaknesses although he ended up being
killed in the end even though the
mountain is a beast and considerably
more terrifying than most of the other
characters I think there are a few
people that could kill him in one verse
one combat he is big and strong but he
is also slow and you can Telegraph the
way he is going to swing his sword which
makes it easy to counter his strikes if
he lands one of those strikes you would
be in some serious trouble but I think
if you approached it like Oberyn did
before he let his emotions take hold of
him
I believe the mountain can be beat this
next character is easily one of my
favourite fighters on the show and that
is Brienne of Tarth
I don't think anyone can question her
skills and if they do they're just lying
to themselves Brienne is one of the very
few characters on the show that has
never lost a fight all you have to do is
look at Bryan's introduction to know
exactly what kind of character she will
be the first time we see her on-screen
is when she is beating Loras Tyrell who
was well known for winning tourneys then
she goes on to fight and beat Jaime
Lannister
now obviously his hands were tied and he
was malnourished but it was still pretty
impressive then she goes on to fight the
Hound who she nearly kills I will say at
the time the helm was not exactly a
hundred percent because of that
festering wound he received from biter
but even on the hounds worst day I don't
know too many other people that would
have been able to pull this off Brienne
is a beast and I mean that in a positive
way she even fought a damn bear I mean
come on not only that but she also
killed multiple stark soldiers at the
same time and then she kills multiple
Bolton soldiers at the same time Brienne
never backs down from a fight and
whenever she pulls out her sword you
know she is going to deliver out of all
the characters that are still alive in
this show Brienne easily falls into the
top three spot on my list without a
question the final character on the list
is Sandor Clegane also known as the
hound this man needs no introduction
his reputation speaks for itself but I
do admit I went back and forth with
where I wanted to rank him and Brienne
because she did beat him pretty bad but
I feel like I have to cut him some slack
simply because he was already nursing a
wound from a previous fight also Brienne
did have a Valyrian steel sword and if
she had a regular sword like the Hound
did
he may have cut right through just like
he did when he fought beric Dondarrion
but there is no way to prove that and
maybe Brienne would have still beaten
him even if he were healthy who knows
the hound has already had three boss
fights the first one was against his own
brother where he's shown he could hold
his own although it was cut short the
second one was against beric Dondarrion
when he cut right through his flaming
sword as if it were butter and we all
know how that ended his third boss fight
was of course against Brienne and they
both put on one hell of a show something
tells me this won't be the last time we
see the Hound faced off against a great
fighter I don't think anyone can deny
the fact that the Hound is an absolute
beast and he may be the only one that is
capable of controlling his brother in
combat which I hope we do see next
season let me know what you think which
characters would you put in your top 10
keep in mind the characters must be
alive and they can only be from the
television show I want to thank everyone
for watching this video I really
appreciate that and I also want to thank
all of you on patreon that continue to
support my channel have a great day
everyone I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]